[Music]
reese witherspoon
julianne hough and more stars celebrate
easter is ready
celebrities posted selfies videos and
sweet family pics to share just how they
spent the holiday their own way Raya
Cary and Nick Cannon's little ones had a
cache filled Easter egg hunt while
Julianne Hough hosted an epic backyard
party for her entire family Reese
Witherspoon looked spring chic to
celebrate the day with her little one
Tennessee my trusty companion Jennifer
Garner jetted off to Honolulu Hawaii
with her friend and personal trainer
Simone de LaRue which happens to be
where her ex Ben Affleck is currently
filming his new movie door busts Bristol
Palin and Dakota Johnson proved their
friendly exes spending the holiday
together with their kids
despite their pending divorce I am
celebrating and Jessica Simpson's
adorable family rocked matching pink and
floral ensembles for the special day as
they enjoyed at doughnuts an Easter egg
hunt and quality family time I will
never
[Applause]
you
[Music]